all right so everyone loves a good
cheese strap
right a cheeky play that shouldn't work
but when it does
it's absolutely five head now you might
expect to see these normally in your
average solo q games but not in
game five of an lcs finals with a
hundred thousand dollars and a trip to
msi
on the line that would be insane if
someone did it then
right well cloud9 did it the mad lads
actually did it and it actually worked
here's how i cannot overstate how how
cool this is
this is game five of the finals this is
not your solo queue game
testing out a new strategy this is the
most
500 iq level one i have
ever seen all right just before we get
into this i want to remind you guys to
subscribe to the score esports
if you haven't done so already that way
you'll never miss a video like this or
any other other great content in the
future
all right so last sunday cloud9 played
team liquid in the lcs
2021 mid-season showdown it was the
culmination
of weeks of playoffs the winner will get
the chance to represent
north america at the mid-season
invitational
one of just two major international
league events all year long the only
thing bigger than msi is worlds
cloud9 were contending for their first
major
title win since signing perks in
november of last year from g2
for a reported 2.7 million dollars
and perks has been very clear that he
did not go to north america
to [ __ ] around he came to take it all i
came here to win and to dominate and
i want to perform well when it matters
and make my fans proud so i didn't come
here to lose any and
did not go to msi so so although perks
has always had
his mind on msi cloud9 had to take down
team liquid first
it was never going to be easy and the
close series reflected that
here's how it happened team liquid took
game one cloud9
fired back in game two team liquid
brought things to match point despite
having a backup jungler for the whole
series
and then c9 leveled things up at 2-2
to send us to a deciding game five
okay so it's game five the stakes
could not be higher it seems like a good
time
to go with your tried and tested strats
right
perhaps it's not the time for crazy
experimentation
or just deviation from what got you to
this point
well cloud9 didn't think so now when
league players talk about a level 1
strat
they're talking about what a team
decides to do at the very start of the
game
often before the minions have even
spawned this could be invading the enemy
jungle
stacking on a bush to hopefully find a
kill or swapping your champions out of
their normal lanes to give your team an
advantage
well it didn't take long for the casters
in this
game five to realize that cloud9 was
doing something
different cloud9 have not been going for
level ones at all
and they are three men top they are
walking this in is this a lane swap
good lord man i think we're lane
swapping against the cho'gath that is a
bad matchup for sion
but i cannot say i expected this now the
invade to take team liquid's blue buff
wasn't super crazy it does happen fairly
often
the other jungler will usually adapt to
this and take their
enemies respective buff in what's known
as vertical jungling
the difference here was that team liquid
didn't know that cloud9 had also
lane swap they'd sent their bot lane to
top lane
and alfari got a pretty nasty surprise
this
is five games in a row ignite's been
dropped vulcan's on the chase
vulcan with a flash vulcan with a pull
over rise how far he knows it even if he
flashes it does not matter
but this was only one half of cloud9's
cunning plan
to understand the other half we need to
talk about the champion
that cloud9 had put their top laner
fudge onto
scion when cyron dies he's resurrected
for a few seconds in
zombie form his attacks hit hard but his
health bar
rapidly deteriorates to nothing before
he
actually dies like properly and he can
actively stay in this form for a bit
longer if he's continuously
punching enemies don't worry about the
logic behind that
it just works i guess so
while the top dive was happening fudge
was taking cloud nine's blue buff by
himself
when he died he came back stronger he
hit blue buff harder and he stayed in
his zombie form long enough to kill the
blue buff
and gromp so this gave him a quick level
two but it also
[ __ ] team liquids jungler armeo
because
now he couldn't vertical jungle sion had
already taken what he wanted
they're going into a split map situation
but they took three quadrants
this is the most 500 iq
level one i have ever seen armeo
desperate for gold and xp was forced
into cloud9 jungle
right where they wanted him and perks
was already licking his
lips blabber with the flash trying to
watch
comes over the ball he goes for the e he
goes for the damage he goes all the way
this [ __ ] just does not happen at this
level of league
in a final game of a series even veteran
x pros like meteos were shocked
this is actually a really [ __ ] hype
game five i can't believe this [ __ ] is
like
yeah a literal game five final strat
when teams go off road at the highest
level of play
it can make history when rox tigers
picked misfortune support at worlds 2016
skt thought they must have misclicked
but the pick was intentional and
completely countered
skt's bot lane and helped rox to win the
game
they pulled that off at world's 2016
semi-finals now
yes that wasn't a level one strap but
the point is these deviations don't tend
to happen
in league's biggest games and that's why
cloud9 strat here
just took everyone by surprise although
team liquid trying to stabilize things
cloud9
held on to their early advantage from
the level 1 strat throughout the game
eventually closing it out to become lcs
spring
champions they stayed in the upper
bracket and cloud9
are your first ever mid-season showdown
champions and what a game
five performance absolutely
incredible they had the confidence the
knowledge
and the composure to pull off a play
that left team liquid staggering for
most of that final game
they had the option to play a bit more
safe but hey maybe
playing safe doesn't win your trophies
ah that victory
means that cloud9 will represent north
america at msi where they'll face off
against the best the world has to offer
but okay let's return to that strat
once more where did it actually come
from like whose idea was it
well coach mithy said they'd had the
strat prep for quite a while and had
perfected it
by watching a rogue game from last year
where they used it to give g2 a real
headache
we used the rogues game from like
last year i think i think was last year
it was against me
yeah against luca so yeah that was that
was also convincing because
it was a pretty rough game for g2 so
yeah i think we we did a few tries we
use our
academy team to help us out and yeah
we were convinced that it was good so we
just decided to show it when
it really mattered basically so cloud9
will be flying off to iceland for their
first
international tournament with this
roster msi was cancelled in 2020 and so
the reigning champion from 2019 is
technically still
g2 and they didn't qualify this year in
fact the only g2 member of that winning
team that will be returning
to defend his belt is perks so can
cloud9 make north america proud on the
international stage
when ma has usually fallen short we'll
have to wait and see
they've been put into the same group as
dam one gaming the current
world champions so it's not going to be
easy
others at the tournament include
europe's new kings mad lions and
either fun plus phoenix or royal never
give up
depending on who wins the chinese finals
this weekend
none of those teams are gonna roll over
for cloud nine and they also have to
respect
the other regions too turkish brazilian
latin american teams have really started
to give
north america a run for their money
recently arguably even closing the gap
on them
are they gonna pull out some more level
one strats against this competition
well let's think for a second the stakes
will be very high the competition
will be very tough the whole world will
be watching
so honestly maybe
yeah from what we learned about cloud9
recently it might be the perfect place
to do it
in fact the only member of that winning
gene
2 who's able ii
[Music]
hello
gene two